Roger Goodell announced that the NFL
supports black lives matter and they are
officially going to be playing the
Africa officially well I don't it's been
suggested that they're gonna be playing
they're considering playing the African
American NFL to play the African
national anthem the black national
anthem before the star-spangled banner'
during all week game one report that's
what it during week one we yeah oh just
for the first week here's my question
here's my clack nationally actually it's
a beautiful song honestly it's a
beautiful song if you've not heard it
it's me I listen to to me it's it's a
really really beautiful song I like the
the yeah it's a great song so but here's
what I will tell you so not question for
you Adam and Josh so say they play the
black national anthem and a white
Republican decides to kneel is that
there during the black national anthem
I'm gonna die okay
I'm gonna purposefully you heard it here
first just a test look I love doing
social experiments you're going to see
me at the NBA or the NFL the second that
they open up those things I am going to
go Neil just to see exam gonna buy a
courtside seat and I'm gonna kneel just
to see the reaction and then we can have
a conversation about how offensive it is
so big court football players don't play
called the court the stadium but you'll
need like little yard line see if they
do it okay what you're saying yeah well
that's a spectacle if you do that by the
way I've got a bigger challenge for you
that's a spider talking about becoming a
vegan losing weight here's what I want
you to do you're a big guy six three
three hundred I want you to drop fifty
pounds put on 50 pounds of muscle I want
you to make it to the NFL I want you to
be one of those players on the Arizona
Cardinals and I want you to kneel while
you're playing as a player now that's
something he's 39 years of what what do
you think about it what do you think
about it it's a shot what if somebody
zero chance what if somebody kneels
what if somebody kneels as a person
during the black nationally someone will
you think someone will yeah is that okay
if someone does I think it's uh I mean I
think it would be clearly a spectacle
and done out of disrespect or to be
or to make a point we've done out of
disrespect yeah like if you're kneeling
number one I don't even know if is
number one I've never heard of the black
national anthem I don't know if that's
even a real thing Adam just walked into
Patrick's trap ladies and gentlemen he
set a trap Adam did not realize he was
walking into just so you know I have no
problem with players kneeling during the
national anthem zero problem III respect
Colin Kaepernick because it was but you
just said disrespect though that's what
you said I'm just saying that I love
watching Patrick do that I'm saying
you're like a cat or did your the cat
you're the owner with the red lizard a
difference between kneeling during the
memory national anthem protesting police
brutality like Colin Kaepernick was the
national anthem has nothing to do with
the police that's why he was protesting
though but here's the deal that's why
Colin Kaepernick was protest bro here's
the thing if I'm protesting then I'm
protesting everything that BLM stands
okay if I kneel but like you just said
people would consider it disrespectful
they would say whoa you know the black
national anthem has nothing to do with
BL this is a topic I'm not to Wiley's
video can you bring the Marcellus Wiley
video by the way what what I will tell
you about this but don't play it yet
what I will tell you about this is the
following here's what I will tell you
the it Roger Goodell he said in the
video that they're thinking about doing
this if that's the case you know what I
will tell you he should have done this
two years ago yes that's what you should
have done two years ago not right now
now watch what Marcellus Wiley says let
me pull it up on here so they can get
the audio if you don't mind they can't
hear the audio that's right because
they're not going to be able to watch it
you can watch it on there that's the one
thing that people what can you blast it
let's see if that works let us know if
we can hear let's test it first guy
first go ahead and play it end
more than just an idea but something
that's gonna be in reality I give the
players positive real quick positive
real quick this is about MBA to paint
black lives matter on courts in Orlando
and MBA may also use social justice
messages on jerseys this is what this
topic is look at the direction he takes
it says quote we dismantle the
patriarchal practice we disrupt the
Western prescribed nuclear family
structure requirement I know statistics
I know my reality for you right now that
children from single-parent homes versus
two-parent homes the children from the
anything about that Adam going to you
first what do you think guys got a super
powerful point I mean it's hard to
disagree with the black man like that
basically calling out black lives matter
I mean how can you possibly disagree so
no objections to what he had to say you
have an objection to that Josh there is
systemic racism in America okay but it's
not the systemic racism that everybody
else thinks this is the leftist ideology
that is the hand the puppet strings
behind black lives matter I will 100% I
have no problem saying black to black
lives matter of course they do because I
believe that every single person is a
human being we are part of the human
race as my friend Myron golden says
we're one race the human race but let me
tell you what the real issue is here the
real issue is the powerful elite that
want to break down the family structure
and I wish I could go into women in the
workplace and the entire ideology behind
some of these super rich people that
wanted to break up the nucleus of the
family but if you really get into the
african-american issues really it comes
down to fatherlessness we've talked
about it a little bit on some of the
God cast when you have the young black
men now look I I pastored in an area of
town that was pretty much the
undesirable area of town we bust in
20-some buses that we would take in and
out of places like about tons of times a
week okay may not have been 20-some
buses but we we sent in at least 20
times a week we would send this into the
what people would consider the ghetto or
the the housing projects the issue is
you have all these kids that are running
around without dads in the home because
the patriarchal system that everybody
wants to rail against it's really a
bunch of people on the liberal left that
want to break down the family structure
if we could get systems where these kids
would would get fathering and they would
get some of that we wouldn't have and we
still have two parent households we
wouldn't have some of the problems that
we have in America period I think that
he's speaking to the exact issue that a
lot of people have why do we have to
support BLM if one of their things is
break down the nucleus system if you go
back to Africa and you study the history
of Africa everything was about the
family not even the individual it was
about the family and the family would be
part of a tribe which was a larger
family everything was about family why
are we trying to break that down you got
anything to say about or no no I you
Steven this one I mean if you're gonna
see if to say I don't want to say
anything because I'm you see it's these
are conversations we should have this is
not my I don't have a family I came from
a broken family I'm doing okay okay
obviously we've seen the stats that
Marcellus Wiley just threw out there it
motivated him to want to be a family man
I'm at a hundred percent agreeance that
the the the nucleus of the family is
that what it's so why is BLM saying that
they want to break down the I don't know
dude I'm not a BLM like oh my god
everything they do is
I'm a dude asking questions you're
obviously way on the right your
steadfast you're sticking to it you're
not trying to move anyway I'm more like
what do you say what are you saying
that's a good point right there all
right cool Hey oh these guys well that's
like there's a lot of people out there
that don't have all the answers and
they're looking for me you seem to have
all the answers okay let me ask you a
very very serious question do you feel
like you cannot weigh in on this issue
because you're white no not at all not
at all because that seems to be that the
overwhelming thing is you're you're
white so you cannot speak to it this is
what I constantly get is that somehow my
skin color does not allow me to speak on
issues because then the second that I
talked about fatherlessness in the black
community now I'm deemed as racist when
statistically it's a problem I love
looking at data I love looking at facts
because when you get away from the
emotion and you look at the data the
data shows you trends every businessman
knows this when you you have to go back
to the data the data will eventually
show you where your problem is whether
you're working with websites and you're
saying whoa we get people right up into
this but they don't purchase here this
is where they go off and you look for
things that you can fix even black
commentators are looking at this and
saying guys we have to get back to the
family issues this is what it comes down
to let me make a quick point when you
see a decline in America when you have
this ideology that is purported upon
Americans that oh you need a two person
income in the house okay I personally
think now look I'm all if women want to
work in the workplace a hundred million
percent I mean some of the smartest
brightest incredible people obviously
are women some of the best leaders are
women I'm saying this though I had the
luxury of growing up in a home to where
my mom did not enter the workplace until
I was I think 17 okay so I was there she
was there every day when I would come
home she'd have that little plate of
cookies which may have been part of the
problem for me and she had a little bit
of sweet tea but my mom was there to
listen to me to talk with me to talk
about homework etc etc unfortunately
people in America do not get some of the
same things today because there was a
idea of feminism okay not femininity
feminism said oh women need to go back
in the workplace from a business
perspective when we just say this and
I'll shut up okay I think this is one of
the greatest scams perpetrated upon the
American people because what it was was
businesses saying we only have this one
labor pool okay which is men all right
so we have to pay them higher wages do
you realize that in like the 1940s and
1950s that the average minimum wage was
today about a hundred and nine thousand
dollars so you could afford a family and
work a minimum-wage job you could afford
a nice house okay but now is that I
could pull this yes extent yes
so Sanford salary in nineteen forty
today would be a hundred nine thousand
dollars which you could support a family
have kids without your wife working
that's pretty interesting Kenneth go
ahead doesn't work that way and now now
they say Oh women belong on the
workplace doing the same jobs as men
blah blah blah so what happens now these
large corporations and stuff get twice
as many a much larger labor pool that
they can pull from which does what to
wages now that you have twice as many
potential workers what what what happens
on the average minimum wage it goes down
it's a scam that was perpetrated on us
now you've got two people that are
fighting to make what one person used to
make so I'm just gonna give you a quick
response and then I would love to hear
pass response so for me as a white dude
you know a single white dude living in
America number one I am in a total
agreeance that obviously Family Values
is key there's um so many stats out
there that point to why family to per to
parent households is so important
completely agree one thing that I'll say
is someone who's not super Pro left or
super Pro right there's a difference
between just saying hey black lives
matter it for sure
black lives matter 100% versus the
actual black lives matter movement and
their mission statement and the leaders
of that movement there's a difference
saying the words and understanding the
actual people running the movement is
totally different from from a layman's
perspective Pat would say I love the
fact that Marcellus Wiley has a job to
be able to say what he's saying
and he's not afraid of saying and I even
applaud the media company that allows
him yet to have the platform without
firing him so I don't know if he's
working ESPN or NB I don't know which
platform that was because I was looking
at the logo I couldn't figure it out
just happen where does Marcellus Wiley
work at is it ESPN if it is good for
ESPN because ESPN has a reputation of
firing people who make comments like
that and I like the fact that he held
him accountable you know the other day
Max Kellerman made a comment on a topic
and he said that's exactly what the GOP
is doing and that our data and it's all
gops fault who's he working for Fox
Sports Center okay good by the way if I
ever had a sporting if I ever had a
sport talks a media company if we ever
ran it that we wanted to get somebody on
sports Marcellus Wiley and Steven
Naismith are at the top of the list
here's why Steven a stops Max Kellerman
says listen stop saying GOP because
there are some people on the other side
they think it's all Democrats fault that
is taking place and I don't want to talk
about politics on a sports show let's
stick to sports and he went into his
messaging right
stephenie's at least keeping people
accountable on both ends and he's going
back to the topic it's one of the
reasons why he is somewhat hated by his
own community sometimes him and
Marcellus I just like the fact that they
both have a job I remember one time when
we were interviewing Steven Naismith
Mario will remember this we're about to
sit down with Steven a and his handler
says look Steven a really wants to sit
down and be on valium and I really want
him to be on ESPN really wants him to be
on there's one question out I want you I
don't want you to bring up with Steven
air so what's that I don't want you
talking about politics I said what if he
wants to he says of course he wants to I
don't even want you to bring it up
because he will talk politics please
don't bring it up think about this
so what we're saying handler what nice
guy professional guy but he's just doing
what Espeon told him to say so I start
talking to Steven and I say Steven
listen you sound like you got more
opinions than just business do you have
strong opinions about politics of course
I do and I said and I said you know if a
media empire hired Steven it which is
contracts coming up in a year and a half
if somebody hired Steven a and brought
him on board say listen do you really
want to be known as sports commentator
for the rest your life what do you mean
do you think that's what how're you
gonna make an impact no I think gonna
make a bigger impact doing other things
like what once you talk about real
issues you're no longer in your 20s and
30s I get it it was a big
to go and be around all these players
you like you know what I'm saying so you
gotta kind of start talking on issues
that really man you got a daughter you
got family now let's talk about some
real issues and you know I think he
wants to but there's also temptation of
knowing when you work for a company like
that you can't really say everything
that's wrong my kids are his political
views I think he's I think he's
independent I think he's very into
probably making an official pitch to
Steven a right now that he has a home
here Steven a would easily get a fat
contract from us if he chose to want to
come to vitami ladies and gentlemen
you're hearing it here first even it
would get a fat contract from us if you
wanted to come and work for my team
[Music]